[Music]
this brings us to the very last session
of the 2017 summer school and this
session will be a little unusual it will
not be just me speaking but we will also
have representatives from the winning
teams of the Mamo collaborative a I
challenge I'm very excited to be able to
hear about their purchase in the end of
this session but first of all I will
give a brief introduction of the Mamo
platform and our long term goals why we
built this platform I will introduce the
Mamo collaborative AI challenge and give
you a sense of the task that teams had
to address there and then I switch over
to our Sean who will be introducing the
teams and there who will discuss their
approaches so project Mamo you have very
briefly at least heard about this
yesterday during the dinner when we
presented the awards to the steam
project Mamo is a platform that my team
and myself have developed here in the
Cambridge lab over the past two years we
open sourced this platform about a year
ago so if this is something that you
think is exciting that you could
potentially use for your research or
used to learn about various AI
techniques for example reinforcement
learning then this is something that you
can download right now it comes with a
bunch of examples that especially if
there has put a lot of time in
developing it comes with sutorius so
this is something ready to try today but
why did we feel the need for developing
and experimentation platform for
artificial intelligence and why did we
select the game Minecraft as the
platform or as the basis for that
particular platform the long term aim of
my research and a lot of people in the
community is to develop AI technology
that allows us to address real-world
applications now when we move towards
real-world applications there's
typically a problem that it's usually
expensive difficult or dangerous to
actually do experiments in those real
world settings that we're addressing in
the long term so there's often this need
that we need to come up with for example
and 11
environment or a simulated environment
in which we can test out and refine our
ideas until we have a good understanding
of how they work and we can actually
translate them into real-world
applications now I see computer games
video games as one particularly
interesting and important environment
for setting up those kinds of
simulations and because in many
important respects they are able to
capture some aspects of real-world
interactions while also abstracting from
some of those characteristics that make
real world experiments expensive
dangerous or very difficult the reason
we selected minecraft is that it
particularly incorporates some of those
characteristics that we are particularly
interested in in the research and where
we also hope to encourage the research
community to look at those particular
problems and they're just three of those
aspects that I want to mention in
emphasize here and there are others as
well the first aspect is that in the
real world
we have a wide range of id variety of
tasks and goals that we are trying to
achieve and that we would like AI
technologies to be able to address but
at the same time those sets of tasks and
problems are typically not some loose
random collection of things that we
throw at for example people or the AI
technologies that we want to be able to
solve them instead those problems are
typically related according to some
rules to some you could say common sense
regularities that we find in the real
world for example typically in real
world environments we have 3d geometry
we have certain spatial regularity that
is very important and all that
information that in that regularity or
things that we can put as inductive bias
into the solutions that we develop and
using those effectively typically allows
us to speed up learning so by developing
an experimentation platform on top of
minecraft we are able to use a world in
which there is this rich but also
regular structure there is a physics in
Minecraft that is not identical to
real-world physics of course but if you
have played Minecraft
for you know that you cannot put water
in the thin air that sand falls down
that when water and lava meet they form
obsidian etc etc so there are all these
rules all those regularities that can be
exploited and built upon when an agent
of an AI agent is trying to learn to
serve a new task in addition to that
what we were looking for was an
environment that could support a wide
range of ideas and approaches and this
is something where minecraft plays a
very interesting role for example in the
sense that it provides the world in
which for example there is a natural way
of discretizing or in some way
characterizing the world inside in many
different ways and just to give you an
example here the platform that we have
built does not presuppose that people
use for example reinforcement learning
you can use a planning or a doctor CGI
approaches but just to give you examples
from the reinforcement learning
literature this is something that I'm
particularly familiar with you can for
example construct tasks that are very
similar to a kind of classic discrete
state discrete action types of
reinforcement learning tasks where an
agent represents the world for example
by those squares those individual
innumerable states that it can encounter
as it as it explores the world and
interacts with it and at the same time
we can move to a different space of
observation so for example the agent
could also observe the the video image
of the world from a first-person
perspective so we provide a platform
where there are these different
observation handlers that give different
types of observations to the agent there
are different kinds of command handlers
and by using those we can create
problems that are specifically targeted
at the technology that we are trying to
explore and it also allows us to start
combining techniques in novel ways and I
think moving forward combining like
combining ideas from for example
different communities has a lot of
potential of helping us address
interesting problems in the future
finally one area that I am particularly
excited about it's this area of learning
to collaborate and communicate with
other agents and in the long term the
kinds of agents that I would want our AI
agents to communicate with are people so
in the long run we are aiming to develop
technology that can collaborate with
people empower them and then system in
achieving the goals that they are
looking for so for those kinds of
problems creating environments where
tasks are based on collaboration and
communication is really important and
the platform that we have developed
comes ready-made for those kinds of
challenges so for example at the top
here there's a screen shot of a task
where two agents are collaborating to
self amaze in the lower run there's a
very simple example of bringing a
natural language component into a task
so these are all capabilities that are
already provided by the platform and the
platform is very generic in the way that
it allows you to create a new task using
a simple XML format putting on some
reward structure or some other
information that should be provided to
the agent and you're ready it can go
about focusing on experimenting with the
agent rather than investing an enormous
amount of time and setting up some kind
of new simulation or some laboratory
setting in which to run the experiments
now after this very brief overview of
project mammal I want to switch to the
mammal collaborative AI challenge and as
we mentioned before the mammal
collaborative AI challenge was a
challenge that we run for the first time
this year and we set this up with the
goal of fostering research in especially
collaborative AI so in developing
modeling or training AI agents that can
learn to collaborate with others this
challenge was open to participating
teams of graduate students worldwide and
I believe Shawn would I tell you more
about the participants that we actually
had it run in April in May 2017 of this
year and we awarded we were able to
award two
as of prizes to the winning teams and
those decisions were announced in June
just about a month ago there were two
sets of prizes one set of prices were
attendance for four livening teams of
the amai summer school right here so
it's a great pleasure to welcome those
winning teams here at the summer school
and the second set of prizes was an
error for research grant and like a
Shimon mentioned earlier in his talk
this is a large amount of compute
resource that we hope will allow the
winning teams to attempt to take their
approaches further invest more in their
research and come up with novel new
ideas and insights in the remaining few
slides of my talk I want to briefly walk
you through the challenge task and
motivate in which way this is
particularly challenging and interesting
and how it captures some of the key
challenges that we need to address in
developing collaborative AI agents and
luckily for me Sherman has already
motivated some of the difficulties in
multi agent scenarios so this goes very
much back to these questions around
games from a game theoretic perspective
the task that we formulated here starts
from the classic formulation the classic
game theoretic formulation that is known
as the snake hunt and you can see the
classic formulation there this type of
game was first described by jean-jacques
Rousseau's who capture some ideas some
kind of challenges in working out social
dilemmas around deciding whether to
cooperate and coordinate or whether to
go for your own reward or safety so the
way this goes this is typically set up
is that there are several hunters who go
on a stag hunt if they want to catch a
stack they need to collaborate because
it's a very large prank if they manage
to collaborate successfully they all get
a high reward so in this example of 200
let's say there could be a value of five
if everyone to everyone who coordinates
in catching the stag eternally each
hunter
try to catch a hair which is easier to
catch can be caught by an individual but
has a smaller has a smaller payoff if
everyone catches a hair they each get a
reward which is fairly safe but it's
smaller than that of coordination now
the conflict arises because if one agent
is trying to coordinate while the other
is going for the hair then the agent
that then then the agent that is trying
to coordinate and collaborate will
actually be empty-handed so they will
get a reward of zero and so this creates
this tension of trying to estimate what
the other agent might do there are two
pure Nash equilibrium equilibria in this
mixed sum game one is where both
coordinate one is where both go for the
hair and then there's also a mixed
strategy that uses various percentages
or various probabilities for one or the
other
now the variant of this game that we
based our tasks on was this extended
version of the steak hunt that was
proposed by Yoshida and colleagues in
2008 and I particularly like this form
of the game because it extends it with
some various aspects around
understanding how to coordinate with
another agent and one aspect that they
were particularly interested in studying
is what they call the theory of mind and
this is this idea that if you want to
compute your optimal strategy then you
need to know some information about the
other agents information state so you
need to know what their what the other
you need to reason about the other agent
strategy in order to counter with an
effective strategy of your own and this
creates again this a recursive dilemma
of reasoning about what they know what
you know what they know etc etc also
this formulation introduces an
interesting aspect of signaling which
you could see as some kind of language
so for example if I'm the green agent
down here at the bottom and I move let's
say to the right
the red agent could infer that as a
signal that you are trying to move
towards the stack that you are trying to
be cooperative so then you can have this
additional dimension where you try to
interpret the other agents actions in a
way that allows you to gain additional
information about their strategy so it's
an interesting form of communication
that doesn't require natural language
per se
now our formulation of the task was a
translation of this game theoretic
Steichen problem into the Minecraft
world you can see here the interface
that we provide for human players to
play the game so you can actually try
this and try this out again this is
something where we provided the tasks
and the baseline start a code on github
so if you would like to play around with
those kinds of tasks you can download
this and try it out we provide two kinds
of observations to the human player and
for the AI agents teams were also free
to choose one or the other the first one
is the first-person perspective which
creates this very difficult problem of
having to deal with partial
observability the other one is a more
global observation basically a top-down
view of the current agent so here I
would be the red agent I could see the
pig and the blue agent position there
and then my goal would be to pick a
strategy that allows me to either catch
the pig by cornering or pinching it or I
could go for safety go to one of the
exit squares on the left or to the right
and get the small reward by abandoning
my my potential collaborator um the task
was set up in a turn-taking fashion so
each agent would act one after the other
however the pig was maintained with
normal minecraft dynamics so it could
suddenly start to run around and there
might be strategies for example in
waiting in a strategic position until
the pig might show up there so I don't
want to say much more about the game and
how it was solved we will hear about
that as I mentioned from the winning
teams in just a few minutes one thing
that impressed me personally a lot was
to see the you
variety of approaches and strategies
that teams tried out for this particular
challenge and our conclusion so far was
that there was no obvious winning
strategy and I think moving forward it
would be really interesting to think
about the various ingredients that made
people be successful in this particular
task and to understand how some of those
might be combined into future more
effective strategies for solving
collaborative games
I just want to compute my slides with a
short-term outlook
I think collaborative AI so developing
AI technologies that can learn how to
collaborate especially with humans has
huge potential for transforming the way
we currently think about how we interact
with machines and what machines can do
for us so I think this is an immensely
rewarding research area and you happen
to be in a position that is perfect for
developing the next generation of
collaborative AI technology I'd like to
encourage you to think about those
problems and if there are any areas that
you're particularly interested in for
example in terms of creating new tasks
for a future collaborative AI challenge
then come talk to me after this talk
thank you so much
[Applause]